das sind weiter zum wetter liegt für die
kinos die lakers kita platz bekommen bei
einem neuen video hier mal wieder auf
einem kanal und so ja ich hab mal wieder
irgendwie richtig bock auf den tag und
den machen wir heute und zwar den traust
du dich tag von bibis beauty palace oder
so hat ihn glaube ich erfunden auf jeden
fall hatte ich irgendwie bock das
draußen zu machen aber das licht ist
einfach viel zu hell und ich würde mich
dann so ziemlich gar nicht erkennen
deshalb machen wir das heute einfach mal
drin ich hoffe dass es auch okay und ich
würde sagen wir fangen einfach an mit
der ersten frage ja und die erste frage
lautet traust du dich deinen schwarm
anzusprechen
also eigentlich muss ich das ja erst mal
gar nicht weil ich seit eineinhalb
jahren freundin habe
ansonsten glaube ich hätte mich nicht
getraut ich weiß es nicht also ich habe
sie so kennen gelernt dass wir
geschrieben haben uns dann irgendwann
getroffen haben ich habe mich jetzt
nicht so getraut ihn anzusprechen ich
jetzt vielleicht hallo gesagt aber mehr
nicht traust du dich vom zehnmeterbrett
zu springen
das kann ja eigentlich nur mit ja
beantworten ich habe jetzt so mit höhen
eigentlich keine probleme und ich
springe auch sehr gerne von so mehtap
brettern zehnmeterbrett habe ich glaube
jetzt einmal gemacht aber kein problem
für mich ich bin heute cool hier geht
traust du dich einen fremden menschen
auf der straße anzusprechen
es kommt glaube ich ganz darauf an worum
es geht aber ich will jetzt eigentlich
sagen auch wenn es irgendwie scheiße ist
würde ich es machen weil es mich
eigentlich nicht wirklich sie die person
im leben nie wieder von daher kann ich
zu ihr sagen was ich möchte
vorausgesetzt es nicht beleidigend und
ich werde danach angezeigt
ach quatsch traust du dich auf eine
öffentliche frauen toilette zu gehen
wenn die toilette seines geschlechts
überfüllt ist ja ich glaube dass tritt
so fast nie im leben auf weil sind eher
die frau toiletten überfüllt als die
männer toiletten
ansonsten würde ich jetzt bewusst nicht
machen falls dieser fall zutrifft
ansonsten ich habe schon ein paar mal
unbewusst gemacht zum beispiel im
ausland da wundert man sich dann warum
sind hier kein steak los und hinterher
bekommt man raus dass man auf der
falsche
vielleicht kennt ihr das hier raus du
dich die alleine einen mega gruseligen
horrorfilm anzugucken
ich hab mit horrorfilmen eigentlich
keine probleme alleine weiß ich zwar
jetzt nicht so aber wenn ich es machen
müsste dann würde ich es auch locker
machen
traurig nicht du musst nachsitzen weil
du eine schulstunde heimlich geschwänzt
hast brauchst du dich deinen eltern die
wahrheit zu sagen
also wenn das jetzt wirklich
komischerweise beim eintreffen sollte
dass ich eine schulstunde schwänze dann
würde ich meine eltern eher nach einer
entschuldigung fragen wenn es darauf
ankommt dass sie jetzt wirklich nach
sitzen soll
dann ist die sache gegessen und die
würden mir denke ich meine
entschuldigung schreiben dann muss ich
halt nicht nachsitzen
traust du dich bei einer nachtwanderung
über den friedhof zu gehen
das war glaube ich so fragen oder sind
zu fragen wie hat man sich mit fünf
jahren im kindergarten gestellt und
einer grundschule lassen dabei würde ich
machen ganz klar ich bin halt keine
traust dich dir deine haare von deinem
besten freund freundin geht schneiden zu
lassen
ja hier die seiten wir waren neulich im
urlaub dann hat mir wäre die seiten hier
ein bisschen kürzer gemacht also das
traurige hier oben nicht so gern so
oliver repp friseur machen dein bester
freund steht nach schweiß traust du dich
ihnen zu sagen dass er die benutzten
soll
natürlich würde ich mich dass frauen
eigentlich gar kein problem ist ja nur
die wahrheit und er wird das schon
verkraften so leicht und ich hab's doch
jetzt doch noch zum strand geschafft
beziehungsweise so fasst also da und es
ist ziemlich bin ich deswegen macht
jetzt hier den abspann ich kann solche
mal kurz zeigen
da ist das meer und ja das war's mit dem
video ich hoffe es hat euch immer
gefallen und falls ihr bock ab dass ich
mit meiner freundin mal dieses wer würde
er video machen
dann schreibt seine kommentare oder
gebten daumen nach oben würd mich freuen
und ja ansonsten instagram und co alles
in der video beschreibung danke für
fette 12.000 abonnenten ich kann so
umstellen und ja hier auf der linken
seite geht es weiter mit meinem netz
video das war auch so ein bisschen schon
hier aus dem urlaub und hier auf der
anderen seite kommt jetzt zu einem video
das ist schon jahre alt oder so aber ich
habe auch hier gedreht also könnt ihr
immer abdecken ist schon älter wie
gesagt aber dennoch ganz okay finde ich
menschheit verblödet oder so ansonsten
sage ich wir sehen uns in zwei tagen
wieder so
bis dahin schöne ferien falls sie
geschafft ansonsten rein